Tony and Emmy Award winner John
Leguizamo has been doing comedy since
junior high school and now he's bringing
his talents to The Daily Show Lego zamo
has more than 150 credits including
movies like Moulin Rouge the menu and
for being the voice behind Sid the sloth
and the Ice Age franchise starting
tonight though Leguizamo is the latest
comedian to guest host The Daily Show
after Trevor Noah stepped down The Daily
Show airs on Comedy Central part of
Paramount John Leguizamo what's up man
how you doing what's up thank you for
having me yes of course thank you for
being here so we were just talking about
this during the commercial break your
comedy was once described as profane
political a teaching tool yeah I was
definitely profane but hopefully
elevating I hope and elevating um will
you be bringing that style to The Daily
Show uh I'm not I'm not sure if I'm
allowed to curse I I gotta check on that
but I will try whenever I can and and
that that that is your signature it's
it's being as versatile as possible you
can talk about any subject yeah what is
your approach going into this week well
I'ma bring it
bring a little next flavor uh
you know I'm gonna break dancing it
you're gonna break dance
but we're actually actually break
something while I'm dancing that's a
good idea break dancing for you not at
this age back when I was a young man and
I'd spin on my head and rip the hair out
of my head and I'm gonna be with Crazy
Legs the the one of the pioneers of uh
legend legend yeah a PR brother and uh
and I have some latinx uh guest stars
that are a flavor and I tried to get
a special guest uh Ted Cruz and Marco
Rubio but they were together you tried
to get them yes snowflakes won't come so
are you approaching this as an audition
because you want this job or you're
taking it as this I'm just gonna have
fun with it what's your mindset going
into it I I I'm gonna go in there to
represent you know to show latinx Talent
latinx Excellence uh that's what I'm
gonna do that's gonna have a great time
I'm gonna blow it out I'm gonna turn it
out did you watch The Daily Show coming
up yeah yeah of course I mean The Daily
Show helped me survive the Trump years
how so I would watch it and be able to
laugh at Find humor about it that was so
dark you know well the Trump years uh he
would like them to come back he's
running yeah yeah for another four Trump
years uh he's also uh he says he's gonna
be arrested soon he might be over this
whole hush money thing do you think
you're going to work that into the show
in some capacity
Waco we're gonna you know the rest the
perp walk yeah but we're gonna work
everything in there go ahead I was gonna
say you're hoping it happens this week
if it happens that'd be amazing
thank you thank you God if it all
happens while I'm hosting that'd be
incredible then I could wear an orange
suit and pretend to be him well that
could do anything I like hearing that
you've been doing comedy since you were
in junior high school so when you
started was it your was it your dream
what was your dream starting out doing
comedy in junior high yeah type thing
because you know my school was mad
competitive for class clowns like you
couldn't sit at the lunch table if you
didn't bust out some great jokes they
will kick you out of that table so I
would have to write jokes at night I had
files for certain jokes for everybody in
junior high yeah yeah you were prepping
for you had to be it was competitive is
that where the title ghetto clown came
from that's right yeah yeah yeah
um so in November you published an open
letter to Hollywood yes um basically
talking about the Latino representation
or lack of yeah or lack of and you wrote
If you look Latino or if you have a
Latino last name the odds are against
you in Hollywood kind of explain your
reason for publishing that and writing
that and where do you think we are now
when it comes to the Latino well I mean
we're the oldest ethnic group in America
where the largest ethnic group in
America we didn't just get here we've
been here for 500 years and and why are
we still invisible we're 20 of the
population and and less than one percent
of the leads in front of the camera less
than one percent of the crew behind what
less than one percent of the executives
how's that possible it's not for lack of
trying yeah you know what I mean we're
30 of the U.S box office we had 2.8
trillion dollars to the GDP we're not
getting our money's worth I want my
money's worth and when we have 20 of the
leads 20 of of the executives and the
storytelling I'll be okay then yeah is
there a moment in your career or moments
that stand out to you where you're like
whoa
that that took me back because there was
judgment or some prejudice against you
oh oh well you know I was up for this
movie the director called me and he
denies it now but he called me and said
I want you in my flick and then he
called me back a week later said oh John
I can't have you in my flick because I
have another Latin actor and I don't
want anybody to think this is a Latin
movie oh and I'm like but the the
original people who was it was true
story of two Latin people
why couldn't a real Latin person be in
the Latin role it just wasn't allowed
yes it was these unspoken quotas and
cheap tokenism something you never know
the audience as well well something
you've never heard too many white people
in this movie we need to do something
about it right right I mean white people
only 58 of the population but if they're
getting 100 of the roles then they're
overrepresented by 140 percent so what
are you working on now that you're most
excited in addition to the guest hosting
of The Daily Show oh the power comes out
Friday based on an international novel
about young women wanting to protect
themselves and through Evolution when
they reach puberty they grow an extra
organ that gives them an electric charge
and they start taking over the world and
flip it over and men can't deal that's
an amazing thought experiment Vlad was
talking about this last week what's your
role if it's about women taking over I
play the stay-at-home dad Mr Mom okay
The Man Behind the powerful woman Tony
Collette and I'm the dad of one of the
girls and it's called spec regulative
fiction because it's based on science
and it's very real it's not magical
powers or superhero unlimited Powers
you've seen you seem excited just
talking about that John I love that show
yeah you know is
we love you and we appreciate you we
love you who's going to call you John
and say you know I didn't care for that
so I'm like what's up
in the business you can watch Donald
guest hosting the Daily Show tonight on
Comedy Central